i know people are worried about the
rising cost of living and that's why
we've taken significant action to
support all families with the most
vulnerable in our society receiving
around 1 200 pounds of help we're also
using all the tools at our disposal and
we have the determination to combat
rising prices reduce inflation and
rebuild a stronger economy
has the bank of england lost control of
inflation is the uk heading for a
recession
now i want people to be reassured that
we have all the tools we need and the
determination to reduce inflation and
bring it back down firstly the bank of
england will act forcefully to combat
inflation secondly the government will
be responsible with borrowing in debt so
we don't make the situation worse and
drive up people's mortgage rates any
more than they're going to go up and
lastly we're improving the productivity
of our economy improving the supplies of
energy we have and moving people off
welfare into work are we heading for
recession
look forecasters will make their
predictions you know but i am confident
that we're providing the right support
to the economy at this time to help
people ease through some of the
challenges they're facing with a rising
cost of living and rebuild a stronger
economy for the long term how would a
wage rise of three or four or five
percent in the public sector be
inflationary when a rise in pensions of
ten percent is not
well it's right that we reward our
hard-working public sector workers with
a pay rise but that needs to be
proportionate and balanced with the need
not to make the inflationary pressures
worse and also to see what's affordable
for the taxpayer now the slight
difference with pensions is pensions are
not an input cost into the cost of
producing goods and services we all
consume so they don't add to inflation
in the same way
okay but for clarity why should workers
show pay restraint when you are giving
pensioners a 10 rise in their incomes
well i think we're confusing two things
because we we already know what pensions
are going to be for this year and people
are speculating on what they might be
next year now we have a long-standing
policy
in place pension rates are decided in
the autumn we've had the triple lock in
place for a long time which protects
pensioners because they are among the
most vulnerable in our society
isn't the truth that you have the extra
tax revenues from high inflation and you
are not passing them on to key workers
but instead you are keeping them for
pre-election tax cuts
what we've announced is 37 billion
pounds of support for families up and
down the country to help them meet some
of the challenges that they're seeing
with rising prices the most vulnerable
in our society are going to receive
around 1
200 pounds of support but there is help
available for everyone it's a package
that has been i think widely
acknowledged by independent commentators
to be significant generous and well
targeted at those who most need our help
at this time